alors vous commencez le livre part
évoqué pour la première fois
publiquement avoir été victime
d'agressions sexuelles et d'un viol
c'est le directeur de l'école dans
laquelle vous logez qui vous agresser
sexuellement mais voilà chaque soir
c'était c'était une bague a pas de
bagarres tous les soirs et il a réussi
le dernier soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre élément qui vient relancer les
soupçons autour de sayabec jubila
notamment des échanges qu'il aurait eu
avec son codétenu marco à la prison de
toulouse seysses où il est retenu il va
lui dire qu'il a enterré sa femme n'est
pas suffisamment profond des confidences
plus précisément qui l'aurait fait
avouant clairement le crime de sa femme
et les raisons du drame il aurait
d'abord vu un message de l'amant de sa
femme avec qui elle texto tu es il a
pris son téléphone des mains et a vu les
messages c'est ça qui l'a février
raconté à marco apparemment que il
aurait donc assassiner des fines est bon
il va carrément lui raconter la scène
des faits va lui raconter toute
l'histoire il lui dit donc autant ciel
c'est un soir il était je crois où
il n'était pas loin elle est en bas en
train de regarder la télé seront
exactement et il explique à ce qu
détenir ce sont les paroles du codétenu
ça bien sûr que ça vaut il a expliqué
qu'il a abandonné il a besoin son
chargeur il va descendre exactement il
va trouver belle fille en train de
texter son amant l'enam aux amants de
montauban savall énervé il va regarder
il à prendre le téléphone et voilà il va
finir par la poignarder et il dira même
au codétenu qui rapporte ses propos ces
imbéciles les enquêteurs n'ont même pas
trouvé le couteau ce qui est c'est sale
ça choquant et crédible marco il dit aux
enquêteurs moi j'ai des éléments et ces
éléments ce sont des lettres que cédric
lui aurait confié parce que cédric
savait que marco elle est libérée donc
il a écrit des lettres pour séverine
mater dans cette lettre les enquêteurs à
leur grande stupéfaction voix demande à
cyril hanouna de nous aider les
enquêteurs ne comprennent pas exactement
pourquoi est-ce que cédric a écrit ça
c'est une manière de dire à séverine tu
peux lui faire confiance parce que cyril
hanouna et le surnom de marco dans la
présenter sa ses bras là c'est un corse
de 36 ans qui porte beau qui a de la
gouaille
l'on surnomme ses marques au parlement
et donc il dit il dit grâce à ça tu peux
lui faire confiance vas-y mais c'est ça
en fait c'est le nom de code c'est le
nom de code de marque au ceba
strictement ccc et du cou séverine va
lui faire confiance fort de sa est ce
que tu penses que si marco son surnom
que ça avait été un nikos lui redonne à
la demande de mise en liberté sera
statué vendredi elle sera vendredi si
cédric jubila reste en prison ou pas va
il va être va rester ou pas comment on
sait qu'il va rester en prison il est
bien là où il ya ce qu'est une jauge je
veux pas me substituer au juge mais mon
avis personnel je pense qu'effectivement
ils resteront ils restent en détention
détention
[Musique]
beaucoup de solitude est ce que la
musique vous a aidé à vous en libérer
je suis pas tout seul à être tout seul
ça fait déjà ça de moins dans la tête et
si je comptais combien on est
beaucoup tout ce à quoi je vais déjà
pensé dire que plein d'autres y ont déjà
pensé mais malgré tout je me sens tout
seul si vous et comprenez vous
l'indignation du journal libération on
va démarrer par allez raymond non moi je
comprends pas la négation parce que tf1
a fait un gros coup ils font les astro
mike froman qui fait un gros coup lui
aussi en allant sur terre ils adorent
vrai que c'était perturbant de voir ça
parce que tu t'ai demandé à une fraction
de seconde est-ce que ça à sa place au
journal de tf1 bah oui finalement ça à
sa place parce que c'est pas que le coc
vide c'est pas que des morts c'est pas
que des drames le journal de tf1 c'est
aussi bien c'est la grande messe mois
pour moi c'est un bon retour il a bien
chanté c'est un truc qu'on n'avait
jamais vu aussi homogène mais moi j'aime
bien les gens qui prennent des risques
on n'avait jamais vu ça à risque et
libération je sais pas ça fait pisse
froid quand même de critiquer un truc
comme ça mais on ne sait pas elle
n'allait pas critiquer ça il n'y a pas
ni rien de critiquable là dedans stromae
c'est un vrai artiste s'est il fait
partie des dés que vous des vrais coups
de coeur merci j'ai eu à 3,10 qui fait
pisse froid mais c'est une honte ce qui
s'est passé et pourquoi
cet homme ce chanteur qui revient pour
faire sa promotion a pris en otage
c'est un super gars des millions de
n'importe quoi mais ces gens accusés une
campagne de ces notions une opération
marketing organisé par son équipe ça
n'avait rien de sincère savourer c'est
fake je ne comprends pas qu à skhira
coudray se soit livré une complicité je
vous le donne mais une opération
marketing tu crois que quand un acteur
toi quand un acteur un chanteur en
autriche il vient dans une émission 3
qui l'attend pas qu'on passe c'est vrai
sa bande annonce vo - straumann et il a
dit moi je vais proposer un truc je vais
chanter sur du débiteur ces questions là
il fait semblant de nous apporter une
chambre n'avait pas du tout bête mais
mettez pas de bêtises les
téléspectateurs ils sont pas bêtes ils
savent très bien que tout a été répété
c'est normal il va pas commencer à se
mettre à chanter comme ça at-il mais tu
crois quoi pourquoi pas jusqu'à au gîte
-puisque quand on dit et il ya des
acteurs qui viennent faire la paix
autre chose pour faire la promotion
c'est vraiment il est au contraire et
l'a déchue chanteur laissez moi faire un
morceau de même en plus vous achetez une
troupe s'était super bien fait avec la
question pour le coup c'est un génie
c'est un maestro il déconstruit
justement la proposition du journal de
20 heures j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire
ils étaient reçus il ya quinze jours
chez jimmy fallon tout le monde crie au
génie et là c'est sur tf1 on va se
boucher le nez jeudi des opérations en
bourse et que la question posée par
claire coudray avant sa performance est
évidemment préparé ce qui est normal
mais on sait nous en tant que toutes les
interviews ont été préparés validé par
stromae est quelque part tf1 un peu
perdu son indépendance éditoriale hier
soir avec que des questions liées
comme il dit non au cirage de pompes
pendant un quart d'heure et ça pas sa
place sur un jt de tf1 que tu racontes
du cirage de pompes et sur les pompes à
toulouse c'est au pas sur les autres
invités ils ont des questions bleues
polémique
dans la dimanche soir dans le jt de
france 2 laurent delahousse reçoit des
artistes alors dresse le tapis rouge
haie il faut y aller pendant le dimanche
soit la raison le jt dont ils
s'emballent c'est beau mais c'est tout à
fait vrai mais lisez pas libération je
ne savais pas pourquoi et bien
maintenant je sais pourquoi je ne suis
ravie ne pas le lire si âgées un texto
d'isabelle elle a fait une belle
intervention la [__]
[Rires]
leur encontre et je voulais rencontrer
depuis très longtemps c'est patrice evra
patrick thaler c'est vrai qu'il avait
une intelligence sur le terrain qu'on
retrouve dans la vie voilà c'est vrai
qu'il ya dedans mais c'est vrai c'est il
est sur le terrain c'est c'est un
monstre a une intelligence incroyable
dans ce qu'ils faisaient et on le
retrouve la même chose dans la vie et
dans son livre patrice evra a love is
game vous commencez le livre part évoqué
pour la première fois publiquement avoir
été victime d'agressions sexuelles et
d'un viol c'est le directeur de l'école
dans laquelle vous logez qui vous
agresser sexuellement toutes les nuits
vous dormiez à l'école ça devait être un
cauchemar pour patrice un mois et ben ça
ça paraissait parfait voilà j'avais plus
besoin de prendre deux trains aime rêver
à 5 heures du matin donc ce monsieur
voilà il me faisait à manger je pouvais
jouer à la console nintendo à l'époque
mais voilà chaque soir c'était c'était
une bagarre à une bagarre tous les soirs
et il a réussi le dernier soir à faire
ce qu'il avait à ce qu'ils avaient à
faire et voilà c'est quelque chose
vraiment comme je dis dans ce monde
lettres noires c'est déjà un désavantage
grandir dans une cité basse et pas jouer
les les gangsters ou les caïds c'est une
question de survie c'est pour ça que
j'ai horreur de ces personnes de ces
célébrités qui disent oui j'étais jeune
un quartier n'en ait pu abus sexuels à
l'âge de 13 ans bah c'est un traumatisme
mais je me suis voilà je suis une
victime mais j'ai horreur que les
personnes disent que tu es une victime
parce que j'ai rien lâché je me suis
servi de ça et ça m'a construit et
quelquefois voilà j'ai eu des impulsions
et agressif ou pas faire confiance à
l'autorité parce que je ne rendais pas
compte qu'en fait ce traumatisme ma
forme et qui je suis qui je suis devenu
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe et le
soir bah ils venaient dans ma chambre
dans le noir toujours le même rituel il
essayait de me toucher donc voilà je
mettais des coups mais j'avais jamais 13
ans et j'attache et je tenais mon
pantalon pour me toucher quand même et
puis il faisait ce qu'il avait fait au
bord du lit et j'ai même carrément un
jour pris les lacets de mes chaussures
est attaché ça c'est ce que vous dit
autour de matin c'est ce que je dis en
détail mais voilà après attacher les
lacets deux attachées à ces à votre
pantalon pour pâques le directeur
boulbès voilà exactement et puis après
voilages explique en détail dans
l'innovation est ce qu'il est ce qu'il a
fait et je rajoutais aussi à l'âge de 24
ans je me suis senti comme un lâche
parce que la police m'a contacté et m'a
dit monsieur vraie écoute et on a des
plaintes contre ce mu avec ce monsieur
et je sais on sait que vous avez dormi
chez ce monsieur et j'ai dit non et
après mon vous êtes sûrs et j'ai dit non
parce qu'en fait c'est pas une question
de 11 mais tu tu as tellement envie
d'effacer ça c'est quand j'ai raccroché
ben voila j'ai vécu toute cette vie avec
ce poids est une femme margot maintenant
qu'ils me disaient mais patch il ya un
problème tu es un super gars mais quand
tu t'énerves cc profond c'est vraiment à
les yeux tu tu envie de tuer et à une
colère et puis après voilà quand on a
regardé une émission sur les pédophiles
et elle a vu mon visage et qui a
complètement changé elle m'a dit qu'est
ce qui se passe j'ai dit rien dit si il
ya quelque chose et puis là je me suis
lâché et je vais raconter j'ai fondu en
larmes et puis à l'arrivée voilà c'est
fou il y avait vraiment un truc qui vous
bloquez s'accroître maintenant qu'on le
sait parce que
mais même moi même je me moi je mettais
tout sur le compte du jeune du quartier
donc c'est comme ça dans le quartier
c'est une question sur lui il faut
toujours se rebeller et cetera mais
c'était plus profond que ça et
aujourd'hui il se sent libérée et non
libérée heureux moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je suis quelqu'un je vis
dans le présent
[Musique]
une voiture qui roule de plus en plus
vite jusqu'à faire chuter brutalement la
victime
la victime ali un retraité de noisy le
sec qui se serait fait piéger en voulant
leur dépanner une cigarette merci à
lille est là oui merci beaucoup à lyon
on a tous vu votre vidéo on était tous
ceux indigné parce qu'on a vivement
remercié également hosni neveu dali
merci
c'est hocine d'ailleurs aussi une merci
d'être là hocine
ali déjà comment ça va
vous êtes abonné mais vraiment je suis
soigné je peux me reposer de temps en
temps j'ai ça fait du bien cet habit
mais quand même ah oui
de la tête de l'humérus fracture du pied
une ecchymose au genou bien les rappeler
au visage je suis reconnu à l'arcade
les mains vont traîner tout seul aussi à
main droite
mais ça va quand même vous avez peur
pour votre vie en ligne vous êtes dit je
vais j'ai bonbons sais mais j'ai peur
quand même de tout esquinté quoi ils
étaient quatre dans une clio blanche
d'accord vous les connaissez cgc ces
garçons le conducteur je connais de vue
il d'airbus venir consommer au bar le
ici et nulle part ailleurs ça s'appelle
d'accord il donc là il vous est
qu'est-ce qui se passe il m'a demandé
une cigarette d'accord a dit ali il m'a
appelé donc il me connaissait madi ali
est ce que tu insignia du loup et huit
en une est sorti mon paquet oui sortir
une cigarette il m'a pris la main m'a
dit maintenant tu vas courir il a
accéléré avec la voiture sur 100 m
shelly lâchement à la semoy il m'est
tombé au bout de cent mètres il m'a
lâché et je me suis creusé la tête que
sur le macadam et diverses contusions et
des fractures après s'est déclaré suite
parce que j'ai mes protégés de bras
gauche mais j'ai pas réussi a dit
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez reçu
des pressions pour retirer votre plainte
ou des oui oui non pression mais hier
matin un jeune homme de 25 ans comme ça
qu'est venu vers moi qui m'a dit hier
place du marchix j'étais vers la place
du marchix et m'a dit si tu retires ta
plante le gars il te donne 1000 euros ce
soir et je dédie au commissariat je
relis je n'acceptais pas ils disent
qu'ils m'avaient dit qu'ils acceptent
est pas parce que l état des séquelles
et oups duré longtemps s'il ya le
conducteur et puis à celui qui a fait la
vidéo qu'il a diffusée et ce qu'ils
auraient pas prémédité ce qu'ils ont
fait est effectivement jusqu'à subi ali
on est sûr de la barbarie est là ça peut
être passible de 10 ou 20 même 20 ans de
prison ça peut être très très graves
apparemment il se reprit au conditionnel
ne se serait pas la première fois oui
alors les suspects ont connu
défavorablement des services de volume
ans le conducteur donc on respecte
totalement sa famille et lui il a déjà
été condamné pour vol usage de
stupéfiants et infraction au code de la
route d'accord ce qui paraît ravi la
place et là c'est beaucoup plus grave et
encore une fois ça devient à votre corps
défendant à limay mais un symbole et
c'est au plus haut niveau de l'état je
pense que les peines seront exemplaires
et elle mérite d'être exemplaire
c'est une image qui fait le tour de tous
les réseaux ça se passe à la eb m school
à gennevilliers une vidéo montre un
élève se faire gifler en plein cours par
un professeur apparemment de ce que l'on
sait pour le moment la raison serait que
l'élève aurait tutoyer le professeur
[Applaudissements]
elle est folle cette session vidéo jour
au début je me suis dit c'est pas
possible merci 6ème d'être là vous êtes
vous êtes élèves de cette classe je suis
étudiante à le business school vous pour
vous tout va bien maintenant vous avez
les renvois en parfaite forme merci
d'être là parce que c'est vrai que hier
sur les raisons on a tous halluciné
comme vous en entendant la castou monde
hallucine qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
fait en fait faut savoir que ce prof
habituellement il est toujours de bonne
humeur c'est pas du toit comportement
normal c'est de vous le disiez empêche
de base était toujours souriant rigolo
il fait tout le temps des blagues jamais
énervé vous allez il arrive dans une
ambiance pas la même pendant quinze
minutes je parle pas il est très
renfermé sur lui-même après le cours
reprend normalement et jazz et du
classique et problématiques de base
c'est pas la première fois qu'il ya un
problème et les profs en fait la ccit en
fait la surveiller c'est quand le prof
et demandent de sortir d'accord donc là
il prépare ses affaires pour sortir
voilà et du coup me sens bien parce
qu'il parle et il lui dit ne me tutoyez
pas et l'élève en question de continuer
à tutoyer et la meute ua du coup il a
vrillé il a fait ce geste déplacé que je
ne cautionne pas mais ça reste anormal
et c'est pas dans son comportement un
beech tree cours normalement après le
professeur qu'est ce qui vous savez ce
qui va se passer maintenant ou pas du
tout non balle les fins je pense que la
directrice va agir en conséquence gilles
vous avez des infos oui alors il ya la
sanction administrative possible et si
jamais il ya une plainte ce qui est tout
à fait possible c'est une plainte qui
peut être déposée pour violence aggravée
par l'élève ou la famille de l'élève et
dans ces cas-là le professeur puisque
très gros puisque la sanction encourue
ces cinq ans de prison et 75000 euros
d'amendé l'élève ou l'avait revu après
non pas du tout non vous avez des news
il va porter plainte il va je pense pas
qu'ils aiment aller jusque là d'accord
après je trouve ça dommage d'écarter ce
professeur après je sais que c'est
logique c'est bien qu'une et l'aide aux
malades aux camarades parce que vous
avez l'air de dire voir ce professeur
rôle aime beaucoup les nouveaux
camarades pensent comme vous mais tout
le monde apprécie ce professeur le
mandatement tout le monde apprécie leur
professeur et et ça ça va jouer moi j'ai
envie de savoir comment elle les lèvres
en règle
non l'a pas dit non non la pâte molle a
pas dit non alors comme dirait mon
général c'est un pote à vous pas non je
le connais pas plus que ça après est-ce
qu'en règle générale la pause et de la r
d ubs a mêlé irrespectueux en baroeul et
les profits l'ensemble de la classe et
perturbatrice en général d'accord après
il fait pas partie des meilleurs élèves
je vais pas vous le cacher ou que ouais
les professeurs peuvent être totalement
à bout et aujourd'hui c'est ce qui se
passe en france de toute façon ah oui
mais c'est pas la première mais en plus
elle dit que tous les élèves eux-mêmes
bien ce professeur donc pour ils
haïssent avait les bons voilà donc
vraiment c'est l'ambiance de classe qui
pousse à vous plusieurs professeurs elle
va lui signer ou quand vous avez vu ça
oui ça m'a choqué venant de lui ça m'a
choqué
j'ai fait tous mes vaccins et c'était à
mais je ne suis pas pour ce vaccin et
pour vous qui allez me géraldine maillet
hors d'elle dénonçant l'irresponsabilité
de tous ceux qui s'opposaient au
précieux d'antidote vous pensez que donc
le coc vite et une grippette il n'y a
pas grand monde en réa mondial des
traitements qui fonctionne très très
bien mais où l'alors on va pas nous
donner les folles et les traitements
surtout pas son intervention lui avait
attiré la foudre de nombreux internautes
s'y asseoir géraldine maillet non
seulement maintenu ses propos elle a
fustigé myriam palomba qui n'était pas
sur le plateau j'appelais plein de
médecins qui sont sur le terrain j'ai
pas appeler aux palombes division face à
ces propos qu'elle juge extrêmement
arrogant myriam palombes a décidé de
réagir jeu depuis que vous avez pris vos
prises de position ça se complique un
peu partout pompe bah oui bien sûr ça se
complique pour moi ça se complique bas
dans ma dans ma vie privée voilà bah
parce que je me dispute avec le mets mes
parents mes beaux parents est d'accord
avec vous non ils sont pas d'accord
alors surgir chagin a renvoyé plein de
sérieuses inquiétudes colère ouais bah
oui j'ai chialé j'étais quoi parce que
font déjà dur oui moi j'appelle pas
palombes à machin dira
voilà que j'ai trouvé ça d'un d'un
irrespect incroyable
alors juste pour lui dire ce que moi
j'ai pas l'habitude d'étaler ma science
et et voilà que de donner mon cv juste
pour vous dire voilà j'ai un diplôme
j'ai une maîtrise de philosophie g okani
cagnes j'ai indiqué comme
j'ai un diplôme de journaliste j'ai une
formation adressé à hec j'ai également
je gère pratiquement 60 personnes dans
mes services je gère des budgets à
plusieurs millions d'euros donc venir me
faire traiter comme si j'étais là la
moindre des moins que rien par quelqu'un
qui a commencé sa carrière dans premiers
baisers et si vous aimez
[Applaudissements]
manger tout ça
j'ai commencé ma carrière à la marche du
siècle et au figaro littéraire donc
voilà alors je lui prêtais ce que je
saurai que j'attendais
moi je vous écoute je suis pas d'accord
avec vous mais je ne suis pas là pour
vous convainc de la même manière que je
ne suis pas d'accord avec des emballages
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi mais
je ne suis pas là pour vous convaincre
et hier quand j'ai parlé de vous en fait
j'ai de la même manière qu'on dit on
n'est pas d'accord avec macro on n'est
pas d'accord avec veron j'ai dit je suis
pas d'accord avec enfin quand je suis
malade je vais pas demander à palombes
awa division faye avait absolument rien
de
céphalées c'est pas l'impression que
j'ai eue quand tu vois là bas c'était
pour moi c'était très très méprisant
mais maintenant
je suis pas innocente ou citoyenne et
vous avez là une sous citoyens je veux
d'abord conditions mais je n'ai pas tout
honneur à la
mairie pas donc elle fait depuis le
début la propagande pour
un
médecin je suis venu apporter et puis
surtout je tiens à vous dire que le pass
vaccinale c'est juste honteux de mettre
des citoyens qui ne refusent de se faire
vacciner au ban de la société c'est
juste ont jeté les directrices d'un
journaliste badens magazines people et
qu'elle n'est pas médecin et donc aux
yeux de plein de gens parce qu'elle
n'est pas médecin sa parole n'est pas
crédible crédit et les nippes et crédit
mais moins crédible que la mienne non
mais ce que je dis c'est que des
personnes comme toi géraldine n'accorde
de la confiance et de la crédibilité qu
parole des médecins engagés d'identifier
était malade si j'étais malade je
n'appellerai pas 10 millions palombes
indépendante et des bas mais que c'est
ma phrase et c'est ce qui a choqué et
heurter effet est vraiment agréable de
son avis
mais pas 10 cm médecin raconte n'importe
quoi depuis deux ans sur les plateaux
télé moi je pense que la crise du coup
vide elle concerne tout le monde chacun
est acteur de cette crise malgré soi et
qu'on soit journaliste people boulanger
chauffeur la toussaint avec ça vous a
choqué ce qu'a fait puisque à dire oui
parce que c'est quand je dis c'est un
délice à vie non mais c'est vrai parce
que je pense qu'il faut donner en gage
du crédit à la parole de chacun on est
tous témoins on est tous à coeur de mes
années
nouveau pas moins que celle de soi
disant spécialistes
surtout quand ils ont un avis qui
diverge du vôtre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]